- WHAT A MIND-BLOWING FINISH
TO AN INCREDIBLE GAME TONIGHT,
WITH CHARLIE SANDERS
WINNING THE GAME
IN LITERALLY
THE LAST SECOND.
UNBELIEVABLE,
TRULY SPECTACULAR.
CHARLIE SANDERS,
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
- HEY, YO, I WANNA SAY SOMETHIN'
TO EVERYBODY WATCHIN'.
YO, YOU CAN DO ANYTHING!
ANYTHING'S POSSIBLE!
THE WORLD IS YOURS!
- AND CHARLIE,
DID YOU THINK THAT THAT GAME
WAS GONNA END
THAT WAY TONIGHT?
- YO, THERE ARE NO LIMITS,
ALL RIGHT?
YOU CAN SWIM
ACROSS THE ATLANTIC.
YOU CAN JUMP REAL HIGH
AND TOUCH THE MOON!
- FANTASTIC. CHARLIE SANDERS,
FRESH OFF OF HIS, UH, VICTORY.
I JUST FEEL LIKE HE'S READY
TO TOUCH THE MOON.
- I CAN FLY!
ANYBODY CAN FLY!
IF YOU BELIEVE IN YOURSELF
THE WAY I BELIEVE
IN MYSELF TONIGHT,
YOU WILL FLY!
- AND WHAT'S NEXT FOR CHARLIE
SANDERS AND THE ORANGE--
- KIDS,
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FLY!
- NO--NO, NOT--
OH, NOT LITERALLY, OF COURSE.
- YES! LITERALLY! KIDS!
YOUNG KIDS, I WANT YOU TO GO
UP ON YOUR ROOFS RIGHT NOW!
- WAIT, WHAT?
- FLY INTO THE NIGHT SKY!
- OKAY.
- PEOPLE WILL SEE YOU FLYING!
AND THEN YOU CAN DO ANYTHING!
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING!
- OKAY, WELL, WE--WE--WE--
WE JUST WANT TO REMIND THE KIDS
THAT OF COURSE,
YOU CANNOT ACTUALLY FLY, KIDS.
- YO, SCREW THAT
NEGATIVITY, MAN!
HEY, BOYS AND GIRLS,
AGES 8 THROUGH 12!
YO, DON'T LET NOBODY EVER TELL
YOU WHAT YOU CAN AND CANNOT DO!
ALL THE PRETEEN CHILDREN
OUT THERE, LISTEN TO MY VOICE!
YOU ARE IMMORTAL!
- OKAY, WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
WE UNDERSTAND THAT CHARLIE...
- [groaning, shouting]
- IS SUPER EXCITED RIGHT NOW,
AND THAT NO ONE IS ACTUALLY
IMMORTAL, NOBODY AT ALL.
- HEY, KIDS!
YOU CAN TURN YOURSELF
INTO A CAR
AND HAVE A FRIEND
DRIVE YOU ONTO THE FREEWAY!
- OKAY, NO--WELL, THAT'S
JUST A METAPHOR, KIDS.
- IT'S NOT!
- JUST A METAPHOR--
- YOU STILL HAVE THE POWER
OF CHILDISH INNOCENCE!
GET A FRIEND ON YOUR BACK,
AND MAKE A BEELINE FOR THE NEXT
RAMP TO THE FREEWAY, Y'ALL!
- OKAY, DON'T DO ANY--
- TO THE FREEWAY!
- HE'S SPEAKING
FIGURATIVELY, FOLKS.
- ONCE YOU GET THERE, AIN'T
NOTHING FIGURATIVE ABOUT THIS!
YOU WILL TURN INTO A ROBOT!
FIRST AND FOREMOST,
I JUST WANT TO SAY
TO ALL THE FAMILIES
WHO LOST CHILDREN, I'M SORRY.
MY STATEMENTS
WERE IRRESPONSIBLE.
I HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY
LOOKED UP
THE TERMS "LITERALLY"
AND "METAPHORICALLY,"
AND FOUND THAT WHEREAS
I WAS NOT INCORRECT,
THEY DID NOT MEAN
WHAT I THOUGHT THEY MEANT.